à saint cyr l'école pour le moment deux
listes qui se profile un duel à deux qui
se profile
on parle de ces élections municipales
dans la ville avec lady di du long pont
bonsoir ça vous êtes la tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun c'est une
candidature qui se veut ouverte et
citoyenne le choix de vous comme tête de
liste a été dévoilée mercredi dernier
comment s'est fait ce choix justement au
sein de la liste ce choix a été réalisée
lors d'une élection sans candidat voit
les membres du mouvement et du
porte-parole du mouvement pour les
représenter à travers des valeurs
d'indépendance politique
nous ne sommes soumis par aucun parti
politique et des valeurs d'humanisme
d'écologie et de transport et du coup
pourquoi être candidat que vous n'êtes
pas issu de la politique locale pourquoi
vous lancer dans cette démarche de
politique locale
j'ai souhaité rejoindre le mouvement
saint cyr l'école en commun ça m'a paru
complètement logique en fait par rapport
à mes activités associatives ou
l'idée c'était de mettre en place des
projets pour la ville pour les habitants
pour qu'ils se sentent bien dans leur
ville et j'ai pu constater qu'il y avait
une certaine limite pour pouvoir mettre
en place des projets et faire en sorte
que la ville soit juste sur la liste
vous l'avez dit elle se veut citoyenne
c'est à dire qu'elle est composée
d'habitants essentiellement il n'y a pas
de personnes qui ont été élus dans le
conseil municipal de saint cyr l'école
par exemple n'ont pas du tout en fait
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
saint cyriens depuis le mois de
septembre sur le terrain et également
nous avons organisé trois grandes
assemblées participatives et où
l'objectif c'était de co construire le
programme avec les habitants et c'est ce
qui a été fait
et se veut ouverte aussi il n'ya pas
d'appartenance politique pas de vous ne
revendez pas d'investiture particulière
non pas du tout c'est ça fait pas du
tout partie de notre valeur c'est même
quelque chose qui a été rejeté par le
mouvement donc c'était pas du tout un
souhait d'appartenir à une politique et
pourquoi je suis à l'échelle d'une
commune gérer une commune l'étiquette
politique importe peu finalement c'est
plutôt les idées le projet qui s'exhale
prévu ça avait pas de sens au niveau
local d'être dus par un parti et c'est s
était pas une volonté alors vous serez
candidat de face et une autre femme
sonia breux qui est maire sortante de
saint cyr qui a succédé en cours de
mandat à bernard de bain qui a été lu de
lui depuis à 2008 et qui a démissionné
l'an passé quel regard vous portez sur
le travail effectué sur certes cette
dernière mandature par la majorité
sortante
ce que j'ai pu constater ainsi qu'un
certain nombre de saint cyrien c'est
malheureusement l'augmentation de la
bétonisation c'est vraiment un discours
qui ressort tout le temps quand je
rencontre des saint cyriens et
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
travailler via le plan local d'urbanisme
donc je vais c'est une ville qui a
beaucoup changé saint cyr il ya une
nouveau quartier qui se sont construits
pendant ce mandat
une explosion démographique et
malheureusement les infrastructures ne
suivent pas donc c'est une recherche de
d'améliorer les services publics aussi
donc lutte contre la bétonisation ça
renvoie l'une des priorités en tout cas
des axes prioritaires de votre démarche
la transition écologique notamment
revégétaliser la ville ça ça fait partie
des des idées que vous avez dans ce
programme
oui tout à fait nous avons vraiment deux
grands piliers au sein du mouvement qui
sont la transition écologique et la
transition démocratique
donc on a l'intention de créer des
instances participatives pour permettre
aux habitants de prendre des décisions
et de sur les projets qui les
intéressent au sein de leur quartier
avec également la mise en place de
budget participatif et en ce qui
concerne la transition écologique
gros retard à saint cyr l'école on peut
pas se permettre d'attendre encore six
ans pour démarrer la transition
écologique est effectivement reverdir la
ville c'est une priorité pour pouvoir
s'adapter au changement climatique qui
ça fait partie des idées ce qu'il y en a
d'autres en matière de transition
écologique
bien sûr il ya la sécurisation des
pistes cyclables par exemple pour que
les familles puissent oser faire du vélo
à saint cyr l'école par exemple il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire sur sur la
question de la circulation à sortir à
l'école il faut vraiment qu'on travaille
sur un schéma de circulation différent
avec un sujet à suivre avec attention
j'imagine c'est l'arrivée du tram 13
express qui est prévu dans les quelques
prochaines années à saint cyr qui
reliera saint cyr l'école à saint
germain en laye
oui tout à fait c'est fait partie d'eads
et s'axe sur donc la démocratie
participative vous l'avez dit plusieurs
idées budget participatif par exemple ça
ça peut être l'une des pistes à mettre
en place pour faire participer les
citoyens les habitants de saint cyr à la
décision comme bien là tout à fait en
fait on a constaté
on a constaté ça en fait au sein de
saint-cyr-l'ecole un manque
d'implication des habitants fin de sa
terre qu ont permis de prendre certaines
décisions c'est sûr ça peut être sur le
nom de la maison des associations mais
vraiment participer au débat
construire en sont les choses avec la
municipalité c'est que ce n'est pas du
tout offert et d'ailleurs ça fait partie
des choses qu'on va mettre en place et
dès le début du mandat c'est une demi
heure de parole citoyenne pendant le
conseil municipal donc démocratie
participative transition écologique est
aussi un autre axe est de recréer du
lien social à saint cyr l'école oui tout
à fait
je suis parti du constat qu' il n'y
avait pas du tout de maisons de quartier
à saint cyr l'école et ses fins c'est
assez rare je trouve dans les villes en
tout cas que j'ai fréquenté j'ai
toujours vu des maisons cartier et à
saint cyr l'école je pense que c'est
très important de recréer du lien
intergénérationnel entre les habitants
et ça passe par la création de lieux
comme des maisons de quartier un tiers
lieux voilà il ya plein de choses qui
n'existent pas à saint cyr l'école et
qui existe même dans les toutes petites
villes de province et par exemple
pourrait créer un fab lab en fait c'est
un atelier de fabrication qui
permettrait aux personnes de réparer
leurs objets par exemple une dernière
question vos prochaines réunions
publiques ça va être le jeudi 5 mars à
20 heures à la salle des fêtes de saint
cyr l'école on retrouve bien sûr en tous
les agents d'adp campagne des candidats
à ces élections municipales sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme merci
lydie du long pont est d'être venu en
plateau de tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun pour le
moment une autre liste 1a qui sera
candidat de face à vous celle de sonia
broc maire sortante avec la liste saint
cyr au coeur 2020